irène chagnaud propose en compagnie de
gilbert le voyage sans passeport
partie seule chasse et le papillon
guyane pendant deux mois gibert le quai
rentrée avec 800 papillon ce qui est
bien et trois films ce qui pour nous est
mieux dont nous auront la primeur qui
dit guyane du bagne
dans quel état l'avez vous trouvé ce
fameux badge ibérique bien à l'heure
actuelle il ya là-bas en guyane un peu
la crise du logement comme on a ici est
la métropole
ouais et le ce qu'il reste de cellules
sur le bagne sont habitées maintenant
par des créoles
alors c'est même très curieux de voir
les créoles qui installent leur linge au
barreau de sa cellule
mais actuellement c'est le bagne vu par
la bannière de l'aider à travers des
dessins puissants et des 5,1 manière a
fait à l'époque du bagne
il a d'ailleurs cédé un petit camarade
kim à l'installer qui tient un
restaurant à cayenne dans les bannières
débarqué à saint laurent du maroni qui
était le principal centre pour le bagne
alors une fois débarqués ils étaient
acheminés vers des camps parce qu'il y
avait plusieurs sortes de bagnards il y
avait les reléguer les transporter
qu'ils étaient tous des criminels
oui enfin il avait une vie assez dur on
s'était un peu la vie de caserne je peux
représenter ça comme ça voyez uv dans
des camps il pouvait jouer aux cartes
il avait assez de liberté malgré tout
les transporter peu qu'ils étaient des
criminels le soir rejoignez leurs
cellules mais le matin ils étaient ils
avaient une certaine demi liberté si je
puis dire puisqu'il est abstrait un
travail forcé saleh devant le guichet ce
n'est pas très très affriolants et voyez
le bagnard sur la droite qui tenait qui
était le porte clés fermer les cellules
par les assassins et abstrait un travail
forcé pour circuler aux alentours de
saint laurent on avait recours à des
sortes de pouce rhuys un drôle de petit
machin sur rails oui c'était glee repart
de bagnard a l'air de l'aide du perche
soyez très longue dans n'importe qui qui
se rendaient en guyane ne pouvait
demander au pénitencier de bagnères pour
circuler 12 et en toute sécurité et en
toute sécurité aux remarques qu'il avait
pas mal de bagnard qui reposait des
forfaits sur place kir tu es là bas il
avait cette maladie lui ces jugements
ils étaient jugés par des tribunaux
là-bas sur place il était souvent puni à
la cellule est offert presque est offert
nous avait les pieds enchaînés
avec deux anneaux de fer voyez une telle
base alors le matin les libérer quand
même une heure pour leur permettre de se
promener dans la cellule de se détendre
si je puis dire
alors tous les bagnards mais la
nostalgie de l'évasion
rien sur malgré la semi liberté qu'il
pouvait avoir là-bas alors bien souvent
par leur travail ils réfléchissent et
comment s'y prendre la plupart du temps
il s'adressait à des sortes de maisons
spécialisées qui organisait tous les
abeba tout l'évasion c'est admirable ça
y avait des maisons spécialisées pour
évasion et bien alors ils payer un
certain prix même souvent il se faisait
fuir se faisait rouler en leur donnait
des des canaux rafistolé qui étaient
peints qui avait bien la pression et
surtout du parti tueur de nuit or il ne
pouvait pas bien fronde contre une en
pleine mer beaucoup de bagnères
d'ailleurs on l'est comme ça disparaît à
chanac
alors la plupart partaient vers le vers
la mer pour rejoindre le venezuela où
vous avez en principe ils pouvaient
s'échapper définitivement provoque
souvent été repris ont renvoyé sur la
guyenne et d'autres remonter le maroni
s'évader vers la forêt mais il se
trouvait à ce moment-là prisonniers
auraient quitté dès fois plus terrible
voilà un magnifique profile alors ce
bagnard que cet habillage d'un bagnard
et a relégué mais il avait fallu quatre
condamnés science qui l'a envoyé au
bagne la relégation maintenant il est
réhabilité mais ne peut plus quitter le
bagne puisque ici en france il n'a plus
de famille et lui même me disait tu l'as
vu une nouvelles de sa mère depuis la
guerre d'ailleurs
alors il reste au bagne
misérablement ils regrettent l'époque de
l'époque du bail
ah bon parce que c'était pour qu'elle
était très bien nourris très bien
habillé en le balançant alors le canoë
conduit par deux bosman et où vont-ils
que se passe-t-il maintenant là ils vont
remonter jusqu'à un village indien qui
se trouve à environ 1 400 km de saint
laurent alors le bannière va les chasser
le papillon il profite de son évasion il
des fois il s'évade et pour cela parce
qu'il ya une industrie qui était né en
guyane 1 sur le papillon le principal
papillon ce papillon bleu plan appelle
morpho minello ce qui est très jolie
tissait en décoration et qui envoyaient
beaucoup en amérique soit disant ils
pourraient contrer les films en couleurs
avec cela arrive remonter chez les
indiens
parce qu'il n'ya point tenir que qui
sont capables ce guide est à la forêt
sans se perdre
oui c'est le cas c'est difficile c'est
le grand danger la guyane c'est super
tout que l'on raconte sur les bêtes il y
à bien des tirs il ya des serpents mais
il faut les chasser pour les trouver
moi pendant un mois de glu par deux mois
de juillet exactement je suis resté un
moment fort et je n'ai pas vu de
certains impôts les tigres et les
procureurs peuvent de bêtes beaucoup
plus agréable pour vous oui
en dehors de votre curiosité personnelle
c'est du tout de même plus ration me
faut empêcher de ramener quelques tu
peux dire oui aux normes plutôt à wayne
de grave inclus mal et puis ya beaucoup
de parasites sur tout un petit insecte
qui vous prie que puis le paludisme sa
maladie
beaucoup connaissent alors les cas nous
voyons à la proche des sceaux qui sont
de forte dénivellation
ils s'étendent sur plusieurs centaines
de mètres certes ils se donnent rendez
vous avec d'autres camarades au départ
de saint laurent il a un mal fou à
conduit alors ici sans trêve les trois
canaux voyant laisse de cannor bas du
saut et tous les bonis de da mêmes
canaux pouces celui ci que le fond est
tapissé de roche
vous avez pu remarquer le drapeau qui
viendra poland et parce que le maroc et
frontière entre la guyane française la
guyane hollandaise
alors ce sont des bonis de son ancien
d'afrique ins et loire qui ont fui les
esclavages et qui se sont installés sur
un ordi c'est très pénible surtout le
panneau continuerait qu'ils transportent
plus souvent deux tonnes de marchandises
reste énorme plus le prêt des hommes le
panneau est à fond plat et le nage un
peu surnage à la façon d'une copine des
lois qui les fait d'une seule pièce au
cannet dans un tronc d'arbre
il est ouvert au feu alors oui tout se
ferait qu il ya sur qu'annoncé pour les
douaniers pour les gendarmes qui se
trouve à 300 km de saint laurent et à
100 km de belvès indien est beaucoup
plus loin et la tenue ce tissu clos
veillée sa facture du boni c'était la
tenue de leur race puis est pas le fonds
pourrait croire qu'ils ont eu ce qu'ils
vous disent tu prends européen qui est
passée par là mais pas du tout je viens
à me chien dans l'émission appels à
scott un petit peu des seules certaines
compagnies comme raymond bannière qui
était bien s'habiller neige sur le canal
8 par moments le canot était pris sur
une roche
alors pour le dégager le beau nick est
obligé de se mettre presque sous l'eau
et soulevé une partie du canot sur ses
épaules est très fort ce sont des hommes
très musclés ils sont pas très fort en
jambes
quoique malgré tout ce dommage est de
faire l'exercice à fait particulier lors
le moteur n'a plus aucune utilité à ce
moment là parce qu'ils se font aider par
le moteur de quelques temps je m'aime et
le moteur fait son apparition depuis une
dizaine d'années sur le revenu laurie ce
fut sur la droite
le fus d'essence d'un vrai pour
transporter et transporter ce cas là
haut
oui rencontre 116 obstacle à tout le
long du fleuve vers des endroits
d'accalmie il y en a même beaucoup mais
plus on arrive vers les indiens assez
haut sur le maroni plus l'ia d'obstacles
plus il ya de roche et à cette période
je suis allé c'était la saison lors de
la saison sèche lors le fleuve baisse de
niveau qui fait que les roches du fonds
se trouvent à fleur d'eau ça complique
un peu voyeur exactement la saison des
pluies qui commence à peu près vers mars
avril
il est beaucoup plus facile on va
bouffer du temps qu'en pleine saison
sèche comme c'est actuellement il paraît
que des fois tu pour 5 km dans la
journée et dans les endroits difficiles
même il me descendait le bagnard rester
dans le canot parce qu'il est habitué et
moi on descendait de peur ce projet
tellement peur remarquez je ne savais
pas nager
lancé sur une entité nord et se jette à
l'eau est incroyable de voir évoluer
sont vraiment dans leur élément
et ça ne les empêche pas ses hommes
d'avoir un a bâti ce qu'on appelle un
bout de terrain qui a été déboisée sur
lequel ils cultivent des bananes manioc
ils sont propriétaires oui alors ils
font sans âme qui pendule et amp ne
recherche pas tellement l'argent il
paraît que les bonis qui aurait 3,89
rendement de l'or sur le fleuve il ya
beaucoup de rivière qui se jette et dans
ces petites rivières sur ces rivières
plus tôt on trouve des villages
d'orpailleurs c'est loin de ce que l'on
raconte sur la guyane
comme quoi entre de l'or appoigny à la
casse baissé pour le ramasser
ce n'est pas vrai en avez vous trouvé
oui ou non les violainois trouver j'en
ai presque jamais cherché bien j'en ai
cherchés oui en filmant ses prises de
vue là j'en ai cherché avec le les
créoles qui est en train de faire son
travail
et puis qui fait le travail vous allez
voir ailleurs c'est très pénible et pour
votre compte personnel un venons on
aurait tenté
résultat la payent leur sortir de deux
jours de travail c'est vraiment minable
c'est dérisoire dans le conforte pour le
salaire si je vous dis oui alors il fait
très chaud conçu des ruches du soleil
vous avez 51° à peu près sûr sera très
pénible une humidité terrine alors le
cours de la rivière et détourner une
partie s'écouler l'autre particulier
vient ici passer dans un genre de silos
en bois dans lequel on met les graviers
du fond de la rivière montrer les et
matin et c'est de là que vient alors
c'est là dedans que se trouve lors en
poussière dès fois en paix pic de sept
kilos mais c'est un peu comme de gagner
un prix national et 50 millions
ça s'est trouvé une fois dans la région
dans celle un peu la fine poussière
alors il avait cette boue dans cette
rigolade dans l'eau et que la panne
d'ailleurs auditionné au fur et à mesure
l'or qui très lourd se déposent au fond
la boue est éliminé par le courant les
gros graviers reste aussi au fond
puisqu'ils sont beaucoup le plus lourd
eux mêmes leur tout ont dans une seconde
rigole va s'accumuler là alors yecla
mail à web
alors le gros qui reste aux français tu
rigoles et la vraie dans une ce qu'on
appelle une batte et non c'est curieux
veiller lors bis et tombe dans le fond
dans le petite conne que forment cette
sorte de chapeau pour ce premier voyage
la semaine prochaine malino et ni mon
ami city contre haibao
la bbc qui conduit au mato nabi citic au
mali
irène joliot vous a proposé voyage sans
passeport cette émission a été réalisée
avec le concours de gilbert luck et de
solange péters montage pierre michel rey
sont paul bonnefond illustration sonore
d'aunis nazaire